[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh we have got company  [Music]  that's right there  in the film Jared you tried out  different laughs didn't you Joker  yeah that it was it very difficult to  you to come up with the right laugh was  it I mean what how annoying a process is  that laugh is an iconic thing so there  was a lot of pressure I tried a lot of  different laughs out on the streets of  New York and Toronto people just thought  something was wrong with you I had one  that I knew wasn't right it was kind of  like that's not really good Caryn his  laugh really bothered you  yeah well whenever I met Jarrod he never  broke character so I would say hi I'm  Karen sukihari nice to meet you I'm  katana and then he would come at me with  hi pretty that was the worst impression  of her  very good a very good wicked witch that  was excellent  you